That day, after working overtime, I was
immersed in my hobby of playing a game. I was in
traffic. Why
would you want to sit next to me at a desk? [Music] Maybe, just maybe, in another world, Claire-sama is cute, Claire-sama.  It's
my road to admire, no, it's service.
Why is this girl so
slow? Her ideas are so slow. You guys have been doing well
since this morning. I was so uninterested that I
forgot, but this is the
world of maiden games. There are
no aristocrats here.  That's the type of person I am. You
can do it anytime. I'm not the type to let people hear it. There wo
n't be a second time. That's how Rei reacts.
[Music]
This prince is the original target.
What is it?  That's funny, I should also mix it up. Ray
bullies Claire too much.
[Music] What are you
thinking, Claire-sama, you're in a good mood.
How could you remain calm when you've been so mean to me? Do you
hate me?  My favorite is
Villain Daughter, which starts airing in October.